[Música]
tiempo para repasar la economía aquí en
directo América para ello Contamos con
nuestro compañero Juan Pablo lucumí y
Juan Pablo bienvenido vamos a empezar
hablando de la economía de Estados
Unidos y es que los minoristas ya se
empiezan a preparar para las ventas de
diciembre allí qué perspectiva tienen
para los próximos tres meses Así es
Rodrigo Buenas noches pues las grandes
minoristas de Estados Unidos como
Walmart y h&m ya anunciaron que
recortarán su monto de inversión en sus
empresas en octubre noviembre y
diciembre una decisión que han basado
debido a la elevada inflación y los
grandes reportes de ganancias menores de
lo que esperaban por ejemplo en el caso
de h&m que es la empresa minorista de
moda número 2 en el mundo su plan de
ahorro de costo será de 117 millones de
dólares un caso particular pues la mayor
parte de su operación está en Europa en
donde actualmente hay una drástica
crisis energética Ahora aquí no hemos
incluido a la ecuación los aumentos de
las tasas de interés por parte de la
reserva Federal tema que hablamos con
Alejandro chaufan colu Forbes y director
gerente internacional de action este
tuto
económico para los tres meses que vienen
no es simple no es fácil y no va a
afectar a todos por igual en Estados
Unidos y en Latinoamérica el banco de
reserva Federal empezó a subir las tasas
de interés y lo más importante empezó a
disminuir la tasa de expansión monetaria
Incluso un poquito a reducirla a
comienzo de a comienzo de año pero no
creo que eso tenga un efecto muy grande
en Estados Unidos porque hay una especie
de tendencia sobre todo en estos últimos
tres meses del año a gastarnos para las
fiestas para las navidades y
en Estados como Texas donde estamos
viendo el precio del petróleo es muy
alto no van a notar una una recesión
Florida ahora acaba de tener este
tremendo desastre natural
pero al mismo tiempo estamos viendo
muchos inversores del extranjero mucha
gente que se está escapando de los
gobiernos izquierdistas de latinoamérica
yendo yendo a Florida Así que el peso
que hay una situación de pesimismo en la
parte oeste de Florida
Estados Unidos es un país muy grande no
son como casi 50 países distintos los
estados Así que no pensamos que va a ser
algo catastrófico este este último
trimestre latinoamérica también va a ser
muy muy diverso no bueno Juan Pablo
Hablamos ahora de cómo está Estados
Unidos en cuanto a puestos de trabajo y
desempleo pues Rodrigo precisamente el
más reciente informe de la oficina de
estadísticas laborales de Estados Unidos
mostró que aunque la tasa de desempleo
cayó del 3,7
igualando el nivel más bajo en medio
siglo la fe de espera que un ritmo menor
de contrataciones y Por ende que los
empleadores no tengan que los salarios
toda una cadena que al final se ve
reflejada en los precios de los
productos para los ciudadanos hablamos
con el invitado y esto fue lo que nos
dijo
realmente hubo un golpe muy fuerte
cuando vino el coronavirus no en el 2020
pero Estados Unidos venía expandiendo la
masa monetaria hace tiempo y había que
pararla y el banco reserva Federal está
quiere dar indicios de que está en serio
tratando de controlar la inflación pero
el público todavía no lo ve Ahora en
estos meses vamos a tener
creo de vuelta un incremento en el
precio de la gasolina que es algo que
todos los consumidores lo ven y lo toman
como un como un impuesto lo que están
pagando no que van a tener menos plata
para otras cosas la tasa de interés al
estar subiendo va a frenar la
construcción de vivendia y viviendas eso
afecta a todo el mundo de la
construcción y a los trabajadores
latinos que están en la en la
construcción pero todavía no ha sido ha
sido dramático Pero nuevamente el para
controlar la inf el público tiene que
estar convencido de que esta reducción
una expansión monetaria que empezó a
comienzo de año va en serio y Va a
continuar y Juan Pablo si no he
entendido mal en este informe también se
ha hablado de los datos de puestos de
trabajo en septiembre en Estados Unidos
cuánto sumo Pues en septiembre de
Estados Unidos sumó 236 mil puestos de
trabajos y revisamos agosto en ese mes
el país acumuló
una diferencia Pues de 52.000 puestos de
trabajo en total algo que entre la tasa
de desempleo y la cantidad de vacantes
laborales se convierte en una balanza
que la reserva Federal constantemente
está intentando equilibrar en este caso
es un resultado que la Fed buscaba Pues
con menos poder adquisitivo circulando
en el mercado la capacidad de compra de
muchos estadounidenses de
estadounidenses baja ahora escuchemos la
respuesta final de nuestro invitado
conociendo ya estas cifras y pues así
poder ver el panorama que le espera a
Estados Unidos en el último trimestre de
este año nuevamente yo no espero algo
catastrófico es obvio que los
incrementos en los casos
el costo de la energía está subiendo
para nosotros los consumidores
domésticos y para las Industrias y los
comercios y todo eso tiene va a llevar
va a llevar un ajuste Así que no va no
va a ser un trimestre súper pero Yo
calculo que la economía va a estar
bastante
planchada digamos decía no creciendo
mucho pero no espero nada dramático en
el sentido en el tema laboral y piensa
que se va a estar recuperando el nivel
de empleo gradualmente en estos meses
Juan Pablo locumis Muchas gracias por
este repaso económico a nuestros
espectadores les invitamos a que sigan
aquí en directo América edición nocturna
porque ya llega una semana en el mundo
de la mano de Santiago López